Hallo Damen, Sie kennen meinen Van in den
Kommentaren. Ich kenne Geschmackstest auf Titan
über Ultrafühler-Cornflakes. Ernsthafte Lebensmittelschiffe.
Verriegelung. Tests auf Spa-Mahi-
Ornament
täuschung
sprache einfach tief ich bin dein bildschirm die
bühne ich bin ein video von englisch clione und
das ist mein heimat komme fast getroffen
schnüffle die spinnen und richte das ulong
von englisch neu aus mein problem mit englisch ist eine
dusche und auflösung freiheit rede von
englisch wenn  Ich starre gut Englisch, wenn du
übst und Beweglichkeit,
okay, die Größenbestimmung des Problems ist das nördliche
Miss-Turnier von - Casa und frischer,
sauberer Ashima, es ist auch Kanaan, als
Esau einen verpfiffenen englischen Dichter sah, wenn
ich so klinge und ich sage, gut, ja, du
musst geradeaus gehen  und dann richtig -
dann und dann gibt's eine wechselstation
lustige duschen oft ein youtube videos von
eckig ist das egal
die ruhe macht diese ungleichheit verbunden
mit einem mangel an  Meine Verbindung als Linguist
für die Verbindung zu Thailand
Ishmael Hör auf, unser Ende zu verbessern, dein Englisch,
so berühmter Mann, ich bin erschrocken auf aha LSU
la cañada Gott kam gepackt und mach weiter,
bevor
ich diese Leute auf Englisch vergesse, während ich mich noch an der Seite hielt.  m von
den Seeottern Alice stand wütend auf
dem Flugplatz ah namentlich in Videos nein ich bin
Stiefel uma ich werde ihn haben müssen - Streaming habe
ich anscheinend als ein gehalten - Zustand meiner PTFE-
Nutzung Newton's oder Kalifornien ist meine nicht
großartige Erica  Dean von Nicks Goodall-
Sitz Durchschnitt haben eine für Spinnen und
Phantasien
Berkeleys Version lecker wie jeder
mein eigenes Vitamin als Amerikaner ein verzaubern
die Augen lieben Anna wie du kannst in jeder
meiner Meinung nach tut Gibbs von Publius
hey Dominator Minutentrainer nur glückliche
Panzerfaust Dean  von Gihon Gefühl zerrissen habe
es besser gewusst als Tony in
Curry-Wissen herumgeschnitzt, aber nicht irgendein Käufer in
Gott.
Ich mag uns von heute Abend an, Nash, weißt du
- super von Kasachen, das ist
ihre Angst, meistens ist es meine
Langsamkeit  Von Englisch nach Spanisch Mein Pony sieht heute nicht
gut aus, weil ich durch die Gasse gegangen bin.
Ja, ja, danke, tschüss,
du
beginnst  versuche es
amerikanisch ernst, weil ich in
deutschland lebe und wir sie hier nicht haben milch
ja ich bin heba sie ein englisch behandelt
midazolam deutsch nicht geschickt etwa die hälfte in
BC und grippesaison chanela bestelle wendy lloyd als verdammter centurion
falle amerikanerin rein und  leutselig und
ich bin oben bei ja, ich bin sehr aufgeregt. Ich habe noch
nie die meisten der ernsthaften ausprobiert. Ich
glaube, ich hatte
einmal Glücksbringer, aber die anderen kenne ich nicht und
habe ich noch nie zuvor versucht, aber jetzt lass uns
nicht zusammenzucken  Probieren Sie einfach einige der
beliebtesten amerikanischen Seriösen, denke ich,
Haftungsausschluss für all diese milchliebenden
Leute, die
ich habe. Seltsamerweise ist dies eine Hafermilch und
sie ist vegan. Dies ist die Barista-Edition
und sie ist hauptsächlich für Kaffee, aber ich mag sie
und sie hat mehr Fett und so  Es schmeckt
reichhaltiger und ja, welches nehmen wir?
Ich denke, wir beginnen zuerst mit Captain Crunch
gesüßtem Mais und Haferflocken. Ja, es
passt perfekt zu meinem eigenen. Es sieht
sehr gut aus. Oh, es hat einen sehr schlechten Geruch. Es
riecht wie meine alten
Socken  rieche zuerst den geschmackstest
ohne mahlzeit
ich bin einfach in meinem mund verschwunden es
erinnert mich wirklich an obstloops und es
schmeckt irgendwie als würdest du nur zucker essen ich
werde nicht zu viel haben weil ich noch
fünf päckchen zum shake shake habe  shake oh
[Musik]
schaut alle hier sie sind alle sehr
lecker mmm hamdulillah hmm oh ich mag sie
sehr sie sind wirklich süß aber ich
mag sie sehr ich denke an
etwas in Deutschland das ich Massen vergleichen kann
nein ihr wundert euch vielleicht zu Recht  ob
so eine skeptische einstellung aber ich weiß nicht
was die textur ist so besonders es ist
wirklich ich weiß nicht ich kann es nicht mit
etwas vergleichen es ist schön
ich gebe ihnen fünf von fünf
ernsthaften löffeln der deutsche mag ist
sehr gut als nächstes  und W  Wir werden
besser im englischsprachigen Spiel. Ich
denke, vielleicht haben wir als nächstes Reese's
Puffs süße und knusprige Corn Puffs
mit echter Reese's Erdnussbutter. Ich weiß nicht
, ob Sie Reese's Pieces schon einmal hatten,
aber ich liebe sie sehr,
Sie können nur  frisst wie einer weil es
wieder so süß und total aufgeregt ist einfach
richtig geil bei
der arbeit auf der tasche hab gerade den minusten
hyperkites tatem gesehen und der ist abgelaufen
weil es der 25. februar ist und
wir haben märz ich hoffe ich sterbe
aber nicht  ja nochmal, ich habe sie vor langer Zeit gekauft
, am besten, wenn sie von den Klängen besser auf
Englisch verwendet werden, weil es heißt, dass
Sie sie vorher verwenden, aber Sie müssen sie nicht
verwenden, bevor Sie sie nach
dem 1. Februar verwenden können. Sieht
dann so aus  Ich füge eine Luftsitzung hinzu, es ist
lustig, weil ich an Atmos-
Flips gedacht habe, damit es nach Atmosphären schmeckt,
weil es Erdnussbutter ist,
es ist Adness und der erste Geruch ist
wirklich Atmosphäre, aber wir versuchen, dass
sie wie Flips schmecken, so sind sie
l  Okay, wir haben helle und dunkle,
die hellen sind unsere Erdnussbutter und
die dunklen sind Schokolade, denke ich, aber
sie sind zusammen in der Packung, also denke ich,
dass sie alle gleich schmecken, wieder
wirklich süß, wirklich zuckerhaltig, nein, ich bin wirklich
so verwirrt, weil sie wie AB-
Nasenflips schmecken, probieren wir es aus, es ist gut, das
ist meine erste Mahlzeit. Ich
frühstücke gerade wirklich
Schokoladenkrispies
und dann hast du Stücke gelesen, außer ich
werde ein Zuckerrausch-Alphabet haben.
Ich weiß nicht, es schmeckt gut und sie haben
wirklich die gleiche Textur wie eine
Ellipse, die du Zuckerüberzug sehen könntest, aber
jetzt ist es weg, was ist der Unterschied
zwischen Reeses Erdnuss  Butter und normale
Erdnussbutter Ich meine, wenn Sie Erdnüsse mahlen
, bekommen Sie Erdnussbutter, es ist
nichts Besonderes,
warum immer ernsthaft Vitamine
drin haben. Ich denke, es ist nur Marketing, also können Sie
sagen, oh mein Gott, es ist so ein gesundes
Frühstück, essen Sie einfach etwas davon  Reese's Puffs
und du hast einen großartigen Start in den Tag. Ich
gebe ihnen wie zwei Löffel, nur Stiefel.
Ägypten inspirierte ein Versagen, ein
Buch wie dieses zu verdienen. Es hat so viel Schmerz verursacht
V Schatz - ist mein Geisternetz Nicht-Koreaner,
aber mein Sohn, vielleicht sollte ich versuchen, selbstbewusster zu sprechen.
Ich denke, es wäre großartig, ah,
ich bekomme ein bisschen ein
wegen dieser Müsli, vielleicht ist es nur
in meinem Kopf, weil ich das denke  Amerikanische
Produkte sind nicht so gesund, aber wer
weiß, okay, das nächste, das nächste, das wir
versuchen, wird kommen, wir versuchen die
Glücksbringer
Es sind Marshmallows, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
aber Lucky Charms sieht einfach so glücklich aus,
und ich denke nicht, dass Sie es essen sollten,
machen Sie sich einfach eine gesunde
At-Cyi-Schüssel oder einen Haferbrei mit ein paar Früchten
darauf und nicht das, denke ich, das sollte es
sein  ein Unikat  rn
du könntest eine Schachtel nur mit Marshmallows gewinnen
hmm,
sie haben eine Schachtel nur mit dem
Marshmallow-Teil. Die Verpackung zeigt ein
anderes Einhorn. Danke, du
bekommst es ist nur Zucker
wie das typische Müsli mr.  granatrote
Glücksbringer sind diese Glücksbringer ja ich denke schon ich denke das ist ein typischer Glücksbringer ich
kenne nicht jedes englische Wort aber ich
denke Glücksbringer sind diese
Klebeliköre und die sind glutenfrei Wow die
haben eine Menge Lebensmittelfarbe  darin
und viele Vitamine, oh mein Gott, dass ich
hier viele Vitamine habe, die so
gesund für deinen
Körper sind, wie Vitamin C, Vitamin A und B,
Vitamin B6,
Vitamin B2, Vitamin B1, Vitamin A, Vitamin B12  vegan
kann die essen oh yeah oh yeah das blau
verliert diese farbe oh vielleicht haben wir danach blaue
milch ja wir bekommen blaue
milch oder so ähnlich jetzt haben wir
so grün blaue milch ich werde es versuchen
das müsli schmeckt nicht  Das ist süß und
du bekommst viel Süße von den
Marshmallows und es ist komisch, denn auf
einem Löffel hast du drei
Marshmallows und es ist süß SL und auf
dem anderen Löffel hast du keine Marshmallows
und es ist nicht süß. Ich bin wirklich geschüttelt, ich bin
süchtig  bis auf die Knochen gesagt, es ist komplett,
ja, ich will  Ich gebe ihm drei von fünf
Löffeln,
der Captain Crunch hat gerade eine wie viele Chaosleiter getroffen,
wer hat mein Magenei gebacken,
bekommt 5 von 5, wir alle haben, wer dieser
Typ ist, wir sind halb durch, es ist wirklich
ein großartiges Zeug für den Tag, wie ich finde  Als hätte
ich jetzt Superkräfte und kann
die Welt erobern, das wäre so komisch, wenn
ich danach ein Nickerchen machen müsste, weil
es ernst war, war zum Frühstück und dann
musst du einfach ein Nickerchen machen, weil
du den ganzen Zucker so satt hast  Eile,
du wirst okay, nächste unsere nächste
Serie, unser Zauberknirschen, mach deine eigenen
Zaubertränke, dafür brauchst du
Backpulver, weiß, diesen heutigen Essig
, Spülmittel, whoa,
bekommst du einen Reset für ein magisches
Etwas, vergiss nicht, es ist dein
Frühstück  Körper, denn das ist sehr
gesund für dich. Frühstück ist die
wichtigste Mahlzeit des Tages,
serviert auf Garys Art und jetzt weißt du
, warum einige Länder ein Problem
mit übergewichtigen Kindern und Diabetes haben. Oh, es
sieht wirklich süß aus,
es sieht wirklich so süß aus und das hat es auch
Marshmallows wieder drin Ich denke es
wird genauso schmecken wie Glücksbringer der
Geruch ist toll wie immer
oh es ist so schön ich kann nicht ich bin so
es ist so schön leckeres Zeug
das Tempo ist okay es schmeckt
gesünder als ich dachte es schmeckt nicht  das
süße
vielleicht ist mein süßgeschmack jetzt schlechter,
weil ich so viel zucker gegessen habe oh aber
das schmeckt wie ein echter marshmallow und
bleiben wir bei meinem stück
okay wir haben etwas okay als nächstes ein
bisschen milch und ein bisschen
ostern umrühren und  dann ein bisschen lecker
lecker
sie haben den film nicht genug aufgenommen als
kind habe ich immer so viel müsli gegessen und
halb voll gezogen und dann so viel
milch drauf und ich weiß nicht ich glaube ich
hab verloren ich hab verloren  meine Fähigkeit, viel zu essen,
ernsthaft Ich habe das Gefühl, dass mein
Herz rast, also Essen, ich muss es überprüfen. Ich
glaube, ich verstehe es. Zuckerrausch 115 BPM. Ich
mag sie nicht so sehr. Ich denke, sie sind
irgendwie langweilig  hat wirklich viel
Zeug drin
Pantone und Soy de Boeuf Levine
Ich kenne Lean ni  et scene oh die sind schon
lange abgelaufen unsere nächste Serie
andere Oreos OHS und die sehen sehr sehr
spannend aus und ich hab einfach keine Lust
mehr
sie schmecken auch sehr süß
obwohl ich sie nicht bei Merck probiert habe  Ich
kann nicht sagen das die Oreos nicht
nach Oreos schmecken schmeckt einfach süß und ein
bisschen schokoladig aber wirklich nicht so toll
und last but not least versuchen wir heute nicht
zu sterben die Kellogg's Rice Krispies
yay hier ist noch die ganze Folsäure  gesehen
Ich kenne Reiskrispies von den
Reiskrispies-Leckereien Müsliriegeln und ich
hatte sie noch nie so mit Milch. Oh, ich habe
vergessen, dass die Reiskrispies nicht schmecken.
Das ist gelesen. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie
Zucker haben. Ja, sie haben Zucker
schmecken eigentlich nach Tory, aber es macht Spaß, sie
zu essen, weil du diesen
Knusper hast, jetzt geben wir ein bisschen
Milch hinein, nein, sie sind gut und bereit für
meinen Geschmackstest
[Musik]
hmm, ich mag die Textur, die
Textur  ist wirklich knusprig, ich glaube nicht, dass
wir etwas im Vergleich dazu haben
Deutschland, aber sie sind überhaupt nicht süß
, obwohl sie Zucker enthalten.
Ich kann keine Süße schmecken, sie schmecken
wie Puffreis. Ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, dass ich
wegen der abgelaufenen Serie sterben werde,
und jetzt muss ich mich entscheiden, welche Art und Weise mein
Favorit ist  Ich glaube ich nehme den
Captain Crunch natürlich dieser Platz
Nummer eins der Gewinner des heutigen
Gewinnspiels ist wirklich Captain Crunch
Reiskrispies auf dem zweiten und auf dem
dritten die Glücksbringer und jetzt denke
ich darf ich aufhören das zu sagen
In meiner Vida von Spielzeugen, die wir bisher verwendet haben,
und einem Undergraduate-
Meuk-Wahn ist dieser Airmen DZ-Krebs aus
ihrer Heimat Mitch McConnell ein bisschen zerrissen auf
fehlende Witze - fehlendes lustiges Zeichen, das der
Schlittschuh der Zündung II ein bisschen zoomt, Harz
Easton war eine neue Nische  Dänischer
Laderaum in Cannes, es sei denn, ein
ähnliches Ich für dieses Video
Leon Flemish Car der Meteorit McCleod
nicht eine erhöhte Strömung auf fein eingeladen
und halten Sie sein ungeteiltes so dieses Haus, wenn
sie dieses Video sehen Schneider auf
sh  arpest ist nett, wenn ich mich trauen
kann und fantastisch angreife, habe einen guten Tag,
sei nett zu anderen Menschen und durch II